deliberate practice is a mindful and
highly structured form of learning by
doing it's a process of continued
experimentation to first achieve mastery
and eventually full automaticity of a
specific skill a 2014 study published in
Psychological Science argues that it can
increase our performance by 26% in games
21% in music and 18% in sports here are
some tips on how to do it well define
success and drill deliberately define
all the elements you need to practice to
become successful then drill each
element deliberately one after the other
in tennis that could be first your
serves and then later your legwork if
you want to become a professional
barista first perfect your moves to make
the espresso then your skills to serve
the ideal coffee plan reflect and take
notes plan out your practice routine for
example in a notebook after each session
reflect and write down what you've
discovered what worked what didn't the
idea is to get a clear sense of how a
particular session improves your skills
and then to experiment defines new and
even better ways to achieve your goals
go slow to build a good foundation of
muscle memory practice slow and
correctly if we move too fast we risk
learning and internalizing the wrong
skills which can bring terrible
consequences to achieve mastery our
brain needs time to develop so start
slow and then gradually increase the
speed until you give it all you've got
limit your sessions to focus deliberate
practice is hard mental work limit the
sessions to a reasonable duration that
allows you to stay focused this may be
15 minutes if you are younger and 60
minutes if you are older Cristiano
Ronaldo does around 3 to 4 hours of
football training a de Young Shaolin
monks practiced 2 hours in the morning
and 2 hours in the afternoon to keep
their attention high they switch the
style of practice every 10 minutes
maximize practice time legendary
basketball coach John Wooden used to let
each of his players practice putting on
socks and shoes so that they learned to
do it really fast by doing this he
maximized the time to practice throwing
the ball and discussing game strategy
with his team tragg small intervals of
improvement if you practice running 800
meters count the milliseconds not the
minutes if you are working out of
practice controlling your diet measure
milligrams and millimeters the smaller
the data points you measure the faster
you see progress and the more you feel
motivated to continue emulate practice
not performance the top performance we
see on screens or on stage is the result
of endless hard work behind the curtain
if you want to become as good as
Pavarotti in the Opera or as skillful as
Messi with the ball don't watch them
perform study how they practice
repetition makes perfect in the 1990s a
team of German psychologists revealed
that it takes 10,000 hours of deliberate
practice to become a professional
violinist a similar study concluded it
takes almost as long to become a great
cigar maker new workers in a Cuban cigar
factory take around 25 seconds to make
one cigar after a hundred thousand
repetitions it takes them just 15
seconds and after 1 million only 8 to
reach peak performance it takes seven
years and ten million repetitions of the
same
hand movements not practice but
repetition makes perfect professional
football teams therefore played daily
what the Spanish players call Rondo
piano players warm-up with scales and
arpeggios routine is everything to reach
mastery young Shaolin monks get up at
5:30 a.m. then chant eat breakfast and
practice two hours of kung-fu at 11:30
they have a vegetarian lunch with no
liquids to aid digestion at around 3
p.m. they practice another two hours at
5:30 is dinner followed by chanting at
8:00 meditation at 10:00
time for bed as normal people can start
with 15 minutes every day and then
slowly increase our session get a coach
the job of a coach is to show us our
true potential and then guide us in the
right direction if you don't have a
coach look for one it can be a teacher a
friend or even someone you find or
follow online for our favorite teachers
and coaches visit a sprouts channel page
and check out our playlists the Dalai
Lama believes deliberate practice not
only works from muscles but also for our
mind he and other wise Minds
deliberately practice taking other
people's anger suspicion and mistrust
and then giving them patience tolerance
and compassion and return what do you
think about deliberate practice can we
also use it for training our thinking
skills share your thoughts in the
comments below
you
[Music]